nous parlions tout à l'heure de rentrer
si vous voulez oublier les soucis de
votre rentrée bien aller au cinéma
engouffré vous dans une salle et laissez
vous porter par un film événement qui
sort aujourd'hui qui a été coproduit par
fr3 qui est de jacques rivette et qui
s'appelle la belle noiseuse regardez un
extrait
avec soin
ouvrir un pub à la télé le rideau
et cet extrait illustre bien le film
s'agit d'un face à face entre un jeune
modèle beaux modèles emmanuelle béart et
vous michel piccoli vous êtes le peintre
c'est un face à face rude violent parce
que en deux mots c'est l'histoire d'un
peintre les faits qui n'arrivent plus à
peindre qui avait qui vit le plus grand
bonheur avec sa femme jane birkin qui
était avant son modèle mais n'arrive
plus à pain dès qu'on lui force la main
me fut un contrat qu'on lui présente une
nouvelle jeune femme qui pourrait être
son futur modèle et il accepte ce pari
de reprendre son travail avec ce nouveau
modèle alors pourquoi la belle noiseuse
pourquoi cet hymne c'est une appellation
un peu anciennes qui vous dira la bulle
cieux zabel en r 2 mai à tous cela dit
avec beaucoup d'amour
oui mais on a l'impression en regardant
ce film qu'au début du moins le noise
heures c'est vous sigean se dire je
ferai ça se dit ça m'emmerdait oui c'est
moi l'emmerdeur en effet mais est ce que
le marchand de tableaux qui me fait
passer le contrat n'est pas apple en
gardent eux aussi
il va tout faire exploser un peu pervers
m'enfin le chef-d'oeuvre existera on le
verra jamais dans le film il veut être
suffisamment de pudeur pour ne pas
montrer le chef-d'oeuvre du peintre vous
avez employé un mot étrange pudeur
oui et c'est un mot étrange parce que
tout au long du film via une femme nue
qui pose pour vous c'est long que
emmanuelle béart
c'est marianne et comment avez vous
réussi à concilier l'inconciliable
elle est nue on la voit nue dans toutes
les positions et vous dites pudeur dans
toutes les positions mais pas dans des
positions
scabreuses oui dans d'une manipulation
physique extravagantes mais d'abord
rivette tête un homme qui a un grand
amour de la femme ce qui est plus en
plus rares jeux l'usiné à ce trou béant
et c'est un homme extrêmement discret
moi je me suis comporté de la façon la
plus discrète possible
emmanuel a beaucoup souffert mais on l'a
beaucoup aidée et c'est une commune
extraordinaire parce qu'on regarde plus
ce au visage je suis las de ces nullités
j'ai entendu toutes les questions que
mes confères opposé à emmanuelle béart
globe en et ciani n'a pas été gênée
justement de tourner nue
moi je pose la question à l'homme et
vous ont pas été troublé je la voyais
tellement angoissé que je elle a été
capable de me passer l'angoissent alors
gelé mis en confiance en me disant en
particulier que si jamais elle croyait
voix de moins un regard qui ne
correspondaient pas ce qu'il fallait
ou un geste maladroit tout de suite
qu'elle me le dise que je ne m'encombre
de rien et je dois dire que chaque fois
que les prises se terminait jeu baisser
les yeux tourner la tête pour la laisser
le spectateur lui ne va pas baisser les
yeux et va regarder ce film tout au long
de tout c'est celle de 700 science ce
face à face entre le peintre et la jeune
emmanuelle mais à partir d'un certain
moment on oublie tout et on attend le
tableau oui mais c'est un curieux film
il dure quatre heures oui c'est un film
sur la création sur l'art sur la
peinture sur les rapports aussi amoureux
magnifiquement magnifié par yvette mais
c'est aussi un film à suspense est très
étrange quand j'ai vu le film terminé
j'ai été surpris à quel point pendant
quatre heures mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer qu'est ce qui va arriver
alors je rassure les téléspectateurs on
peut le regarder pendant quatre heures
ne s'en lasse pas mais vous vous ne
craignez pas que
il n'a y pas par crainte de rester trop
longtemps dans la salle on ne sait pas
où vous savez on avait déjà beaucoup de
craintes ce film était demandée par le
festival de cannes c'est d'y aller à
cannes avec un film de quatre heures et
un plus d'un film de rivette c'est
dangereux et bien ça a été ne soyons pas
modestes a triomphé est-ce que ça va
continuer le moins de public le public
seul le terrain cela dit c'est un film
qui haut-rhin a publiquement sur les
années futures et rassure très
douloureux pour les producteurs mais je
pense qu'il s'y retrouveront il a en
tout cas obtenu le grand prix spécial du
jury à cannes merci beaucoup mieux des
communes à vous merci